la confrontation avec la russie est la
seule raison d'être de le temps disait
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov
en août le dernier rapport sur la
stratégie de l'alliance jusqu'en 2030
vient de le confirmer en qualifiant la
russie de principale menace jusqu'à la
fin de la décennie
les auteurs du document baptisé hot en
2030 unis pour une nouvelle ère et
affirme que le bloc atlantiste doit être
réformée de toute urgence
le rapport stipule que le temps devrait
faire preuve d'assiduité de solidarité
pour faire face un acteur comme la
russie tout en gardant un esprit ouvert
pour un dialogue éventuel au cas où les
autorités russes choisirait une voix dit
plus constructive
ces formules n'ont pas laissé
indifférente la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
marie et zakharova s'obstinait à nicole
daniel blais les idiots mais nous
n'avons jamais été les idéologues d'une
organisation régionale ou internationale
quelconque faisons bloc et agissant
selon le principe d'amitié contre quel
karine sportive 42 rouge en achetant
qu'à sao paulo - quant à l'expérience de
l'otan je tiens à vous rappeler
l'opinion du président français selon
laquelle l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale après avoir entendu une telle
évaluation du président d'un pays
membres de l'alliance
on se demande si l'expérience devrait
effectivement être répétée aux potes
khamouli banque postale hier le
secrétaire général de l'otan jens
stoltenberg a fait savoir que la version
finale du rapport serait présenté au
prochain sommet de l'organisation
militaire en 2021 bruxelles la
publication du document intervient après
l'appel du chef de l'alliance à
renforcer davantage la présence des
membres de l'organisation aux frontières
de la russie sur la péninsule de crimée
et la mer noire ainsi que la nécessité
d'accroître leur présence navale dans la
région